[Music]
i've been really looking forward to
watching the bulls in person for the
first time they've been so fun as curry
launches and connects
firstly
talking about sending the turn
setting the tone the first play sets the
cross screen
now he comes down
[Music]
good job not selling that three-point
line sells the shot fake and then puts
his head down and attacks a lot of
contact there curry for three
that's his third
this can be discouraging when you play
this type of defense and a guy
just shows his greatness little upper
body strength there's ten and one
they're only lost in overtime loss at
home to memphis
that started this
long home stand steph curry starts off
the third with a three
all this action is fake you have to pay
attention to steph curry at all times
that's a post up for draymond green
they're not trying to post up draymond
green to the three-point shot these
bulls all so far this season they've
been gritty and tough curry another
three got it
26 for curry this really is how about
this
steph curry says allow me to have this
dance
what i mean by that a physical defense
you have to meet force with force
it's surrendering too much curry for
three it's good
the relationship they have the eye
contact tell them get out of there
already understands it
this is time for me and steph to make a
play simple basketball
still a long ways to go the old state up
by 15 right now
largest lead 19.
curry again
and that's draymond green it was a
terrific story in the athletic marcus
thompson and darnold mayberry wrote
about how these two is curry launches
the three knocks it down
derek jones
let's get a little sloppy wiggins kicks
it out curry puts up
[Music]
[Applause]
the most games with nine
uh he has 36 of them that's wild
and harden is second with nine ever
lillard nine ever even clay seven he's
different
kobe